Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update microsoft has several reasons why
the Xbox one is lagging behind the
PlayStation 4 in sales Microsoft chief
marketing and strategy officer Yusuf
Mehdi commented on the disparity saying
it's really hard to assess the gap in
sales Sony is in many more markets right
now than we are there in forty plus
markets we're in 13 the Xbox one is
slowly expanding its global footprint
releasing in Japan and 25 other regions
in September according to Medi another
reason Microsoft isn't selling as many
consoles as Sony is people have been
more satisfied with the xbox 360 than
the ps3 so in that respect people have
less of a need to upgrade in the short
term due to regular updates for the xbox
360 we could point any number of things
Oh Yousuf Yousuf Yousuf well among the
any number of things that they could
point to games appear to be one of the
important ones Mehdi said as we go into
III you're going to see an incredible
games lineup knock on wood I believe
we're gonna have a great games lineup
for this coming holiday season as well
knock on wood don't you know what your
friggin lineup is for this holiday
season Oh Youssef what are we gonna do
with you buddy well III just around the
bend and we're gonna have a ton of
coverage of it here on gamespot of
course if that is you can tear yourself
away from how satisfied you are with
your xbox 360
ah Yusuf I Yusuf